okay welcome uh everybody i'm maury
samuels and it's my great pleasure to
welcome you here this afternoon to the
last talk in this year's benjamin and
barbara zucker lecture series
today's speaker david deyoung is a
correspondent in the middle east where
he writes for the dutch financial daily
among other publications
for the research and writing of nazi
billionaires
he reported from berlin for four years
before that deung was a reporter at
bloomberg news in new york where he
wrote about hidden wealth and in
amsterdam where he wrote about european
banking and finance his work has also
appeared in the new york times the wall
street journal and bloomberg business
week deyoung was born and raised in
amsterdam
and currently lives in tel aviv
nazi billionaires is his first book
and many of you probably uh saw his
really fantastic um hard-hitting op-ed
in the new york times last week so
hopefully we'll have time to discuss
that as well as well
uh so a word uh first about how things
will work today uh david will speak for
about 40 minutes and then we will open
it up to questions from the audience
please submit your questions using the q
a function at the bottom of your screen
uh we won't be able to see or hear you
but you can submit questions at any time
during the talk using the q a function
and i will relay them to david
um
so
yeah so without further ado it's really
a great pleasure to to see david again
who i got to know a little bit in berlin
um last year and uh really excited to
hear more about this book which i've
just been reading and i have to say is
just a fantastic read in addition to
being about you know completely
fascinating subject matter it's it's
really well written it reads like a
novel so i highly recommend it to
everyone all right now i will hand it
over to david
thank you so much maury for that kind
introduction
um i am going to be talking about
the families in my book who i think the
five families i write about in my book
who i think very much
very well represents or their patriarchs
at least
very well i represent uh this kind of
you know german big business or at least
an overview of german big business
because these families were then and are
still today
germany's most prominent uh business
dynasties
um
and i want to start it off with i'm
going to try and condense a century
from 1919 to 2019 in about 40 minutes so
i'll be zigzagging through the five
families but i'll start off with the
main family the quant dynasty whose
heirs today control um control
bmw at least two of the heirs it's still
germany's wealthiest family today
and
their patriarch gunther quant loses his
wife antonia in
the spanish flu of 1918 and in the
fall of apartment in the
spring of 1919
he takes a um
night train from berlin
to castle in the center of germany and
he meets a
well not she's not even a woman yet
she's a girl a 17 year old girl
called magda friedlander margaret
friedlander who
just came out of a relationship with a
jewish student named khaim al-azerov who
later becomes a very well-known
zionist in israel and his and is
shot dead on a very mysterious
circumstance in 1933 on the beach of tel
aviv she comes out of a relationship
with with with with a lot of when she
takes that night train
in easter uh in the easter weekend uh of
1919 and she meets gunther quandt
magda friedlander um
is
the
her stepfather is jewish and she's taken
on his last name richard friedlander
but she was
baptized
catholic and raised catholic
and she
um
meets gunter quandt and they go and they
and and guterrent was 20 years older
than she is
is completely enamored with her and um
when
magda gets out
at her stop in in central germany and
goes to the boarding school where she is
you know he finds her address and um he
writes to her that very night when he
arrives at his destination
and he takes her out on a date and
within three days he proposes to her
gunter has two sons from from from his
first marriage
and he proposes to her and she after
long considering or after
yeah some consideration she says yes
and they get married
uh or she says yes and they get engaged
now however
to get married
he has one condition country juan has
one condition or two condition that she
reconverts
from catholicism
back to protestantism which is he is
lutheran
and
um secondly that she drops the name
friedland friedlander before she gets
married and that she reassumes
her her birth name
which was her
her biological father's name
um because
you know
of course from his perspective
you know he could never get married or
grindr could never get married to a
woman who holds a jewish last name and i
think that is very much
that episode where the book start where
my book starts with is very much
emblematic for the thinking of the
families or at least the patriarchs of
the families
i'm writing about
this this latent anti-semitism
um as opposed to
the really
racial anti-semitism this convinced
anti-semitism
these these men i write about are not
they are not convinced anti-semites they
are
you know for the most part protestants
who you know very much in lutheran
theology
you know is is is is is
you know
if from my view deeply anti-semitic also
many
voters who voted in the nazi party
um there was a far far higher votes for
the nsaid bay
in the more protestant parts
of germany
who saw hitler really as a sort of
reincarnation to many of martin luther
so it is really this
is this this latent uh anti-semitism
that is that is prevalent not only in
the circles of big business but i would
say
unfortunately for the most part of of uh
of christian
uh german society both protestant and
catholic uh at
that time
now gunther quandt
who's already from a very wealthy family
a textile family um
builds up this empire during the the era
of hyperinflation
as does
um
his uh
well
fellow industrialist friedrich flick
who ends up being
probably germany's most notorious
industrialist of the 20th century and
who is eventually convicted the only one
of my main characters who's eventually
convicted at nuremberg for a crime for
war crimes and crimes against humanity
the two of them separately
um start very much profiting from from
from uh the hype the era of
hyperinflation
in the 1920s
um gunther quant
um
manages through through hyperinflation
which wiped out most of the middle
classes but for the speculators of that
time the stock speculators of the time
was a very profitable era
um
managed to
take control of a global battery factory
alpha and a global
or a weapons factory a weapons firm
called
dwm and that is really the groundwork of
the quant
business empire that they see that they
very much profit from for well after
hitler sees his power in 1933.
now as for friedrich flick
he uh parlays a
a steel company that he controls into a
steel conglomerate he takes over the
united steelworks uh during the during
the hyperinflation era
and
it is very interesting to see how
virulent anti-semitism is already
leveled against the kind of the jewish
speculators
of the great jewish speculators of that
that era
in
germany where there is this idea of you
know they're just speculating they're
they're they're they're
they're um
you know accumulating stocks and they're
accumulating controlling interests
in in companies uh you know
across across the board of the business
spectrum uh from from from industry
to
to to to textiles to to to battery to
weapons
but
these
these
these same accusations
you know which you still see today
leveled against
george soros or the conspiracy theorists
who you know you don't see them leveled
uh against pedro quandt and friedrich
flick being you know
uh
protestant uh
parts of the german uh establishment
now i want to go to to to 1933 and and
hitler uh seizing power in germany
um
the
quickly codifying of of of um
of anti-semitic laws in in germany you
should quickly see the main uh well
characters in my book taking advantage
of it
um
um
[Music]
gunter quant um gets briefly detained
because at this point in time
his his um
marriage to to to magda uh
quant is uh has dissolved and magda
quant has on to become
uh magda gobbles
she divorces
uh guterre quant in 1929
and
soon meets
um
joseph gobbles who's then the uh rice
yeah the rice propaganda lighter for
for uh for berlin
and is you know up and coming in the in
the den still
burgundy uh nazi party um and they soon
become the um
you know the the most prominent couple
of the third reich
and
a custody battle ensues
sons from his first marriage uh herbert
and helmut
and
two
and and and has one son uh together with
magda called
called harold
and a custody battle about harold uh and
zeus
and
um he is arrested
which he later prepared is on uh
gribble's orders he's arrested on may
4th 1933 three days after grinter kwanz
becomes a member of of the nazi party
he spent six weeks in um
in custody
and then as soon as he gets out and he
first has to go into house arrest he
starts firing
um
[Music]
you know the the uh jewish
members of his supervisory boards and
executive boards
he starts removing them uh from from his
from his company boards
um
even though he says you know the bear he
later prepares himself to be a victim of
gobbles and a victim of the nazi regime
and as an opponent even though he he he
becomes one of the third reich's largest
profiteers um
and
he
you know take it quickly takes advantage
of business part partners that he had
there was a banker named jacob goldsmith
which both friedrich flick
and and
did a lot of business with and was
served on on on on their company boards
uh he is above quant and flick is is
swiftly removed
from from his boards from their boards
and um you know is forced to flee nazi
germany
and that is again emblematic also of the
thinking of these men they they are not
convinced anti-semites
uh but they are they are willing to play
along with the region with with with the
nazi regime as long as it benefits their
companies their fortunes
um and
uh you know they they will not do
anything that goes against the rules
um
by
you know
going the extra mile
um to save
their jewish colleagues or employ
employees
from
persecution
now
following the
the the
implementation of the nuremberg race
laws in mid-september 1935
where of course the disenfranchisement
of of of jewish citizens in nazi germany
really ramps up
you see
this
um concept of arya which later became
known as aryanization
really
enter into
the discourse for german businessmen
and
the concept of ironization
was
this
idea of the removal
of
of the jewish element
from
the ownership of an asset whether that
was a jewish-owned company
shares
jewelry
art real estate
that's where it starts and of course
initially these transactions still have
the veneer
of a regular business transaction
um between i would say
1935 to 1937
but they very soon afterwards become the
outright expropriation
and appropriation
by the nazi regime
as well as the businessman i'm writing
about i mean i give countless examples
in my book
of arianization
um
but i will
[Music]
give
several and the most prominent one i
want to start with
is
the
removal of out of rosenberger the
co-founder of porsche
of the porsche company by his jew
or the buyout
is the is the correct is the correct
term
of out of rosenberger by his two porsche
company co-founders
anton pierre
and ferry non-porsche
they the three of them
start the car design company in 1930
in um in stuttgart
and they
you know on the day that that out of
rosenberger resigns in january 1933 30
30 of january 1933 is also today that
adolf hitler sees his power in germany
he resigns rosenberger because he is fed
up
with
being he's a commercial director of
porsche and he's fed up with
you know being the financial backer of
the porsche company which is
blowing through money uh on the
expensive designs of ferdinand porsche
the
mercurial
car designer
[Music]
and and whose company you know it's
namesake company
out of rosenberg has 10 of the shares
he stays on out of rosenberger as a
um
porsche shareholder
until july 1935 when he's bought out
of uh the porsche company at the nominal
value of his shares
uh which was three thousand reichsmark
now
at this point in time
ferdinand porsche has convinced uh uh uh
has convinced hitler to put his design
the volkswagen into production
um while the porsche company was verging
on bankruptcy uh uh on january 30 of
1933
by the time uh july 1935 comes around it
is a very profitable company
however out of rosenberger is bought out
for the nominal value of his shares
um
3 000 heist mark which is far below the
market value of his actual shares and
that is
again
and that is a
stereotypical form of aryanization the
way these transactions were conducted
they wanted to remove
uh pf and and porsche wanted to remove
apple rosenberger
as a shareholder
which
out of rosenberger later contends is
because they wanted to have
a classification
as a
company which was
you know free of jews
um and
you know out of rosenberger
um
who
is is is ready to leave germany he
actually is then soon after he gets
bought out of porsche
uh detained in a concentration camp on
the charge of racial defilement
and is helped by his successor as
commercial director
helps him to to to be freed from the
concentration camp poor champion don't
do anything to help their co-founder out
um
and later a whole legal battle ensues
and um
the other families in my book quant as
well
great are
great greatly profits from uh from
aryanization um
he uh
acquires the companies of uh
several battery companies uh owned by
german jews far below the market value
of um
of their shares
and friday flick actually becomes the
largest profiteer of er or at least
largest privately uh
of the private businessman he becomes
the largest profiteer of arianization he
takes over
um the massive uh pet shack
brown core conglomerates in central
germany
in um one um
for uh six million dollars also far
below the market value of uh the shares
of the of one branch of the patriarch
dynasty and the other one is outright
expropriated
by
by the nazi regime and he
ends up in a acid swap
with those bronco acids
as well
another um
the fourth family i write about uh in
the book it's uh aubust von fink
and i was from fink i write about both a
senior and junior
um
they uh
are is a co-founding uh financiers
family of allianz and munich re
um today two of the large two of the
world's largest insurers and reinsurers
and
um
i was from think senior
uh his father who co-founded alejandro
munigree
his father dies when he is 25 and he
inherits these you know the largest
stakes in these insurance companies as
well as a controlling stake in the in
the family family's private bank mark
fink
and hitler asks him in 1933 because he
is you know as nazi officials call him
bavaria's wealthiest and uh
and stingiest man
he asks him
uh
if von fink can fundraise as he refuses
to spend any money of himself
on um
if he can fundraise for the house of uh
of german art which is a
which is hitler's pet project
uh a new museum on the southern border
of the um
of the uh english garden in munich
and um
from fing readily says yes
and is is happy to to to and ends up
fundraising 20 million reismart from his
fellow tycoons
and and financiers for the building of
for the building of that
museum which today is still a very
prominent
building
in um
in munich
and as a thank you for his successful
fundraising efforts
von fink is rewarded rewarded by arie by
being allowed to arionize the rothschild
bank
um
which is the
um
austrian branch which is austria's
largest private bank and the austrian
branch
of the rothschild uh
family
and
he's also allowed to ironize in berlin
the drifus bank branch
and
he
does so he first does so by the museum
opens in 1937
and he uses also
um
you know the code for the the the laws
of nazi germany in in a way also of
attacking
not only of ironizing these private
banks which you know expands his
business empire significantly
but also
by
um attacking his his fellow
private bankers
which was greatly dominated by by you
know there were a lot of
uh
[Music]
private banks at the time owned uh by
jews
many who have been around for
generations
he he
uses that he utilizes the
anti-anti-semitism
in
very in vigorously attacking
fellow private bankers and
so successfully
that you know
his
attacks and then his subsequent
arianizations
cause a kind of a bank run on on on
other jewish owned private banks and it
is you know it becomes performs kind of
the blueprint
for the as they called it
dejuification
of germans uh private
uh of the german germany's private
banking system
and
i was from fink becomes the largest
profiteer uh in nancy germany
of of private banking organizations
the last example i want to provide of of
the families that i write about is the
um
utker kazolowski family
uh richard kazolowski is the ceo of dr
utker a large begging good conglomerate
um
who
who steps on who is mentoring his
stepson hood of iris utker
uh to take over as ceo of the of the
doctor utger pudding empire this is
mainly a european-based conglomerate
still today
very well known for its frozen pizzas
and um it's
pudding mixes
and richard kozalovsky
um
is actually one of the few men who is
like an ideological uh national
socialist
um he is really convinced
uh he's convinced nazi the other
examples that i gave of the other
industrialists and financiers
are
for the most part
yeah our opportunists
who
who
you know leverage anti-semitism and and
the government and and and the laws of
nazi germany to their business advantage
whereas fisher kausalowski is such a
convinced national
socialist
that he
actually
it's to the detriment of dr rutger's
business because they own for instance
they own not only a a baked goods
company but they also own a publishing
company and they merge a or or
kazolowski's instigation they merge
a
very highly profitable
newspaper that they have with a nazi
publication that is bleeding
money
and this steps out of august utker who
ends up voluntarily
applying and joining the waffen ss
um at one point he goes to hamburg he's
eight he's 21 years old in 1937 and he
acquires the house
of a uh of a jewish executive who had
who fled to to australia
and it's actually the only time in the
book where
somebody where kazulovsky warns his step
his stepson
who he mentors he says
be aware
the
to this house
tears stick to this house i mean i cited
in the book
and it is it is
quite confounding that the only kind of
sense of remorse or a sense of
forewarning
in the context of an arianization i
found was of somebody who was an
ideological nazi he wasn't so much again
he wasn't he was also a latent i use the
word latent anti-anti-semite
he was not a racial anti-semite
kazolowski also had many
jewish business partners
who of course he swiftly got ties with
following 1933
um
but it is the only instance i came
across during my research and that of
the one uh ideological nazi where he
warns his uh his stepson of what he is
about to do with the ironization that
you know of the moral implications that
there are of course his steps on the
hood of argus utkar who became one of
germany's most prominent post-war
industrialists
shrugs herself and and buys the the
house of the flood uh uh tobacco
executive far under the market value
of his shares
so
these are really the bulk of the
examples in the arionization period
i want to move over to the um
to the post-war period where frederic
flick stands on trial in 1947
um in
the the nuremberg trial that is led by
um
it's a subsequent nuremberg trials of
course you have the main nuremberg trial
where 24 of of of nazi germany's most
high profile politicians
and um
military leaders were indicted and
convicted
um but there's but under the american
purview you have 12 subsequent trials
and
the flick trial is one of them friday
flick is indicted and convicted
on
charges of war crimes and crimes against
humanity
and the trial is led by
the prosecutor general whose name is
telford taylor
and he writes or sorry he says in his
opening statement
the defendants will tell you that they
were not anti-semitic and even protected
individual jews against the nazis
yet it was not beneath them to appear in
public with
and pay a king's ransom to himmler the
assessed leader andre himmler who all
but rendered the jews extinct in europe
they threatened on the misfortunes of
wealthy jews
etc etc
and friday flick in his defense says
well
i'm actually a exactly what what what
telford taylor says in his um
in his opening statement friday flint
uses the defense well actually i was a
protector of all jews even though he was
the largest profiteer
of of organizations in in the third
reich says i protected
the jewish businessman uh
whose companies i acquired and you know
uh
in order not to
have the suspicion for on me i sometimes
also made you know a casual anti-semitic
remark
um during the organizations um in many
of the memos you find
some you find some of his very off-hand
uh uh anti-semitic remarks and he said i
did that in order to not be too
suspicious and not to have the
suspicious
uh suspicion land on me
that you know i was a supporter of uh of
uh of the jews which of course is a
completely inverted
reality and a perversion of reality
i want to
give two more examples i want to go to
the late 1970s in which ferry porsche
the son of fernando porsche and the man
who who
receives
out of rose rosenberger's shares after
his father and his brother-in-law by uh
by rosenberger out of the porsche
company in 1935.
in 1976 ferry porsche
designed the first porsche sports car
was also a voluntary ss officer
voluntarily applied to the assassin 38
entered the ss or was
admitted to the assessed in 1941
and ends up um
surrounding himself
with high-ranking former ss officers at
the porsche company of course then a
global sports icon in the 1950s and 60s
in 1967 in his first autobiography which
is solely published in the united states
by double day at the time
it's called we at porsche
for for the porsche sports company the
american market is the most important
market
he has
no trouble at all
um
spewing virulent anti-semitic vitro
about out of rosenberger
uh who
who he accused of extorting him
and his father and his brother-in-law
and the porsche company after
uh the war ends and rosenberger tries to
um get compensated for being
bought out of the porsche company for
under market value of his shares
so and he writes the following i want to
read that part as well
almost a decade after rosenberger's
death ferry published his first
autobiography we at porsche in it the
sports car designer not only twisted the
truth of rosenberger's ironization and
escaped from nazi germany but also did
the same with the stories of other
german jews who were forced to sell
their firms and flee hitler's regime
ferry even accused rosenberger of
extortion after the war what's more the
former s officer used blatant
anti-semitic stereotypes and prejudice
in his worked account
after the war it seemed as though
those people who have been persecuted by
the nazis considered it their right to
make an additional profit even in cases
where they had already been compensated
rosenberger was by no means an isolated
example where he writes very now in his
mid-60s supplied an example of a jewish
family who had voluntarily sold their
factory after leaving nazi germany for
mussolini's italy
only to return after the war and claim
payment a second time at least according
to his interpretation of events
fairly continued it would be hard to
blame the rosenberger for thinking in a
like manner he no doubt felt that since
he was jewish and had been forced out of
germany by the nazis who had done so
much harm he was entitled to an extra
profit
so
that latent anti-semitism that and this
is quite explicit
that i referred to earlier
to those patriarchs and those those
industrialists in the bahama republic in
nazi germany this thinking
for many
continued unabatedly in the post-war era
in the um
and in in west germany
um you know without any without any
ceasing i mean the fact that fairy
porsche felt so confident to write this
down in english in a in a you know very
publicly in his very publicly published
first autobiography goes to show
how
common and widespread
uh this uh you know
casual use of anti-semitic remark uh you
know
that he dare to put it in in such a
uh you know public in his first
autobiography
which was first published in english and
only later two years later four years
later published in german
but to give give an indication of that
thinking today
i wanted to conclude
on um
by by giving the example of august von
thinks c is junior who is the son
of august from fink
uh
senior
i was from think junior died in this
november at november 2021 in london at
the age of 91.
he became after his father died one of
germany's most
secretive uh and most successful
investors
and somebody who
started funding
uh german uh
conservative right-wing and ultimately
far-right causes
and
um
he and he did that
over
a three three decade period starting in
the 1990s and ending or at least
to what it has become known to the
public
ending
in uh
the late odds around uh 2017
and there is a he worked together his
right hand man a man named aaron sknude
style
um um was kind of his money man
and the man who would be served as a
conduit between i was from think
juniors political spending
and and the anti-eu anti-euro
libertarian
uh conservative or or free-market
liberal
causes he would donate to
and at one point there is a lunch and
this happens in may of
2017 in munich
there is a launch
in in in uh
in it happens in munich there's a launch
that anticlint style has
with a uh
um
he's trying to recruit a publisher for a
new
right-wing publication or far-right
publication
uh in germany
and he
says
reportedly at that meeting he says
there's danger ahead from think junior
travon think juniors lieutenant said it
mean there's a street in new york with
lots of investment bankers lawyers and
so forth go incidentally they are all
jews but that's not relevant here they
want to push germany into rule they
control everything
says aaron scootsdale during a may 2017
meeting in
lunch meeting in munich
to give you an example of how
you know this is a prominent businessman
and he's the right-hand man to one of
germany's wealthiest
and most prolific political spenders
over the past couple of decades
to give you just one indication of
unfortunately how prevalent is thinking
and saying still is
so i would like to conclude it on that
note thank you i look forward to your
questions
okay
thank you so much um
david and there's really i think a lot
um to
uh dig into here and i urge everybody to
please submit questions again
excuse me using the q a function at the
bottom of your screen and i will
um filter them to david but i have a lot
of questions um of my own so um first of
all if you could just start by saying
what was your most kind of surprising
discovery uh doing this research um i
imagine you know as you make clear you
know some of this was known already at
least in in certain ways but some wasn't
so like what to you was your your
biggest find i think actually the out of
rosenberger storyline uh which i added
latest to the to the book um it was
actually
my partner pointed out to me a
documentary that that was broadcast on
german
television in summer of 2019
which brings up
the
the
the fact that alex rosenberger was
completely erased from uh from porsche
company history and the fact that you
know porsche such a global icon such a
global brand had a jewish co-founder who
was not only
you know uh
bought out far below the market value of
his shares but was also just completely
erased from company history
and it actually turned out to me that
was
the biggest surprise
on a on a kind of on a
micro level of stories
but i think on a macro level and a
bigger picture i think and that also was
the reason why i wrote started writing
the book in the first place
was uh to
was the fact how you know brazen
the whitewashing today still is by
companies like porsche and bmw
where they have all these
you know global foundations in the name
of
of uh
partner of fairy porsche and and um
and herbert quandt who say bmw from 1959
celebrating their business successes but
leaving out
you know
any part of their of the war crimes they
committed or the nazi affiliations
that they had and you know after these
families and these companies prepared it
to have reckoned with their third rank
with their with their
uh nazi era histories and activities
and and i think that especially in this
day and age
and i got this idea back in for the book
back in 2014
and it um
you know it didn't change in those eight
years i mean they had eight years to
come clean about it but you know i i you
know luckily for me they didn't because
you know i could
i could
you know but i thought every day it's
like i thought every day it was going to
be it was going to be like they're going
to yeah yes exactly i'm going to get
scoop i'm going to get front-runners
news
um okay so
um
you know as i was reading the book i
kept i had a running dialogue with
myself like well which are the worst you
know like there are yeah i kept kind of
going back and forth
and clearly they're kind of varying
degrees of guilt but i'm wondering if
you had a thought about which one you
thought was the worst well i i do think
the the the quant or at least the two
quant siblings that today could well you
are you talking about the patriarchs or
the like the entire families or yeah
both yeah
i mean in terms of patriarchs i think
they i can't really distinguish
i think they're they're they were all
equally
awful in a sense uh but i do think that
those families today
that control the families like the
quants or the bmw or the siblings that
control bmw today
um the quan servings that control bmw
today as well as
the
the porsche pf clan and and the porsche
more to an extent
uh get control porsche but not only
porsche but also volkswagen audi bentley
etc
and that have these outward facing
foundations and corporate headquarters
and even media prizes named after these
men without being transparent i think
they are the most blatant in in the
cover-up of of the history
and i think also because they control
such global brands and and have such
global outward-facing companies they
also have a bigger responsibility to be
transparent about the history
so a question from the audience um could
you say a little bit about um
what conditions were like in some of the
factories that jews had to work as slave
laborers um
in
this very much different i mean and
there were also
there were also
for the most part
jewish or slave labor done by by by jews
who were
kept in concentration camps for their
you know for
their for
who were not
sent to extermination camps right
because that's that's the distinguish
we're talking about here at this point
you know they were kept in
sub-concentration camps where they were
deported from concentration camps to the
factory complexes
at volkswagen or at gupta quant and
herbert quan's
battery factories
and
you know they were kept in the most
you know there were i know at quan's
affa factory
uh outside of hanover there was a
gallows you know there were abusive
couples who who beat uh uh prisoners uh
uh sometimes to death
um um i mean it it ranged i mean
on on the lowest bottom of the rung
were the jewish slave neighbors
um followed by
by
mainly slavic forces slave laborers
millions who were deported from poland
ukraine um russia and and belarus
and other eastern european countries
um
and you know western europeans
for the most part were
comparatively
treated much better i mean
yeah which you know wasn't even you know
pretty bad but yeah yes yeah so okay
another question um
can you give examples of big german
firms or
individuals that refused to collaborate
with the nazi brazil regime so did did
you know i imagine some refused maybe to
actively profit from aryanization but
can you give any positive examples here
i mean you have you have there's the
example of robert bosch who was his
industrial very well-known industrialist
and is the company that he left behind
bosch which is owned by a foundation not
owned by family anymore
um the company he left behind
you know is still one of one of the
world so who is a massive industrial
partner is a master of electro technical
conglomerate today
and he was a very progressive
industrialist really took care of the
labor conditions for his
uh for his employees
um
already going back to the to the uh
kaiser raich and obama republic
and he was very much anti-hitler
and he but even he even he and his
support through his right-hand man
funded the resistance uh to the extent
he could i mean he died in 1942
to robert
did and he
you know but even he mass-produced
weapons for the third rack and used for
use and forced labor was used in his
uh in his company in his company so and
he would say he's one of the you know
positive examples
i mean
you know that's the most positive
example i can give
across the board
forced
and to a lesser extent slave labor was
used
by
by german business yeah
uh and arianizations
you know ironizations occurred
you know this was a business decision
right this was a catholic so it occurred
only if they made sense
you know
these businessmen didn't make
uh ironization acquisition if it didn't
make sense for their business expansion
so these were all these were all
business deliberations that they made
does this asset make sense can we get it
for the right price
because we're called calculating
decisions yeah so
so so so for instance conglomerates
conglomerates who didn't do any
ionization it doesn't mean that you know
that that that says something about that
they were any better than than than
gunter cuando friedrich flick who did
it was just that it didn't make sense
actually such acquisitions didn't make
sense in there overall i mean
you know m a strategy in their in their
corporate development strategy you know
okay i'm feeling a little bit better
about my dishwasher but a little bit
worse about my coffee maker
now so
um so
question about um
what the allies did to push for
punishment of these
you know firms or wealthy germans after
the war uh was there any effort of the
occupying allied you know in in as part
of the denotification process
i mean it starts with initially it
starts with the morgantown plan robert
morgantown jr who's the treasury
secretary proposes the morgantop plan
which basically called for the entire
dismantling of germans industry and the
summarily execution not just the
political
and and military leaders but also of
business leaders
that plan is scrapped and instead
you have this plan that is mainly um
drawn up by john j mccloy and his boss
stinson in the in the war department who
you know also
you know if you can talk about the
anti-semitism of
of german big business but of course it
was rife
in the american state department and and
war department too
and they come up with this plan which
envisions the nuremberg trials
uh
oversees the occupation and the dividing
of an occupied germany between the
united states and the united kingdom
and also
oversees the
as they called it which was part of the
four ds
densification was one of them
but so was decartalization and
deconcentration of german industry which
in the end does not really it doesn't
really happen to a large incentive
it's only iga farben is a very prominent
example
of at the time the largest
uh chemicals and and pharmaceuticals
conglomerate in the world
split up in what is today
bisf and buyer still two of the largest
companies in the world uh in
pharmaceuticals and chemicals
respectively
but for the most part of course the cold
war emerges
and and
you know
initially harry truman and then like
eisenhower but particularly truman makes
the policy decision
uh that we that that the united states
government needs a viable democratic
or economically viable and
democratic west germany as a bulwark
against an encroaching soviet union
and all the aspirations and ambitions
that they had for the reform of german
society
and and and and denotification it all
quickly goes out the window
and
the aim the overarching aim becomes the
build-up of uh of west german
uh society as a democratic and a
capitalist state yeah um
yeah so um
some people are asking you know you
really focus on kind of heavy industry i
would say in in the book but you know
you clearly could have talked about you
know some people someone raised the
question of like the entertainment
business um you know uh and i imagine
that there were kind of similar stories
going on in all different aspects of you
know all different areas of the german
economy is that true would you say or
well listen i mean i picked i picked the
families i picked the business families
of those that are still most relevant
today in in europe in german european
and global business
so that it could have you know
i think
in a sense
the
businesses that i chose and i think
that's why they're also so emblematic or
so exemplary of the larger wider
business community and their faults is
because they they do range i mean sure
could your country flick
a big industry
but one would say you know porsche pf
car
car and then and then of course um
[Music]
the
front fink is in is in is in finance and
he occurs in consumer goods at that time
yeah right so it does it does
give
the two main characters are indeed in
heavy industry
but i wanted to focus on those families
that are relevant today so what
regardless of what industries they were
in at the time uh
of the nazi era yeah and you know the
your opening kind of um scene where
these um these rich germans are summoned
to a meeting with hitler is incredibly
chilling where like you want you know
there's a lot you know how are they
gonna react and they you know are more
than willing to help finance yes
so here a bunch of people have you know
put forward a really interesting
question that i had too which is
you know you end the book on a
maybe hopeful note saying you know we
will do better right uh but a lot of
people are asking
what that would look like so what do you
hope your book accomplishes uh what
what kind of reckoning are you hoping
for
at the bare minimum is is this and
that's also the idea i went into i mean
the book is an argument in favor of
historical transparency and i think at a
bare minimum
these families should be
with the massive consumer brands that
they control should be outwardly
transparent
about
the the
the histories
of the
vaunted patriarchs that they call their
foundations and global headquarters and
brands and and and media prices after i
mean i think that is a bare minimum that
we can expect and if they don't want to
do that
then you know i think they should they
should they should rename they should
they should rename you know that is what
a reckoning that is what an honest and
transparent reckoning
uh looks like to me
because i also think you know one learns
from history by showing the good
and the bad and if you just celebrate
somebody's business success but leave
after war crimes especially today when
we live in an age of such you know
disinformation
uh all across the board you know
these families particularly have a
responsibility not only to the consumers
but also through history to be
transparent about it and you know you
cite i forget which one it was but like
the a young woman now who just recently
gave a speech that where she's just
completely
it's not even like they're trying to
hide it anymore and she's almost like
you know like the past what does it
matter i'm i'm i'm rich yeah yeah yeah
um
so
i you know and it's very troubling which
is a very troubling indication for where
germany's headed yeah we spoke she spoke
after cough but you know i mean kind of
the blatant
lack of any historical
knowledge yeah and and kind of any sense
of morality that foreign displayed not
only during that speech but all
particularly in the follow-up comments
that she gave to build uh to build the
church right it's a food company like
they have a thousand thousand it's a
very famous yeah but there was some
shaming and kind of um boycotting it
seemed like after her speech so there's
sure and i i i end the book all the way
in the back in the notes of sources
where she gives this interview in
september 2021
to the zoo deutsche side room
about how you know she forced now forces
her family to talk about it and
therefore she's forcing him to be more
transparent about it but it's still
difficult yeah so i mean i do i am i
mean to get back to the previous
question
you know i am hopeful about my
generation even though some show
you know uh a blatant lack of of
knowledge about about that period party
you know particularly those german and
particularly those who are end up being
the heirs
yeah uh um because i do think in the
four and a half years that i lived in
germany
and i i know that in the in the in the
opat 2 in the si2 in the new york times
is that i everybody is is extremely
aware
and and is extremely reflective
and is
is trying to to to make a better german
you know and of course with its
political and economic might um
you know
is extremely important
yeah i mean one of the kind of
fascinating things is you described that
many of these families have hired
historians to uncover the truth about
their past but somehow these histories
wind up
almost seeming like part of the cover-up
in in some ways i mean they're kind of
you know but intentionally in some cases
in most cases completely unintentionally
and in some
intentions
yeah i mean you said they're actually
kind of good historians often but then
the book comes out and they think
they've done everything they need to do
and then nobody you know the historians
and their research i mean it's also
insulting to the historians and the
researchers who work on this project for
three four years and then these studies
come out and they are only
published in dense academic german and
then you know nothing changes and then
the findings you can't find anywhere
except in like a 1200 page study in
dense academic german
and then it also begs the question who
then exactly is this reckoning with
right because for the most part the
germans of course were not the the the
the victims of the crimes of the these
patriarchs of these and their businesses
right so but but but you know surviving
forces slave laborers and their heirs
never get any access to these details
yeah so
so it very much backs the question you
know and then
you know when when when when a company
or a family then doesn't do anything you
know just goes to show that they don't
to me it doesn't it goes to show that
it's not an honest and transparent
reckoning
they've initiated
so your book is about to come out in
german also which is um you know
fascinating so what do you
imagine the reaction is going to be
you're gonna do a whole um you know book
tour there you said um
yeah like have you gotten any advance
sense of what you're doing no i haven't
no no i mean the book is gonna come out
the german translation is gonna come out
may 5th i mean the two translators and
the editor and myself worked extremely
hard
on the german translations
to be the best
version
it i mean you know the english language
version is also great
the even better version of that one
and and um
and
you know really worked on a day and
night particularly in january december
january and early march
um and
you know i i got a sense actually the
man who inspired me to write the book or
gave me the idea for of the book
as um a german journalist who wrote
biographies on the quants and utkers
and
he actually i had sent him a a um
i'd send him a um yeah
an advanced copy of the book and he said
i woke up to this morning with a note
from him and that he said he read it in
one go and he said i learned a lot and
it's really well read and we're really
well told and et cetera so that's
i mean in a way he's my most important
critic since he inspired me to write a
book back in 2012
2013 um or gave me the idea that i
should write about this topic in a way
not explicitly but but
through the interviews i had with him at
the time um i i got the idea and
you know
in a way he's my most important critic
so the fact that he approved of uh of it
already goes show uh ammo is already
very happy yeah that's fantastic okay
well we're out of time but i want to say
thank you so much for um sharing your
your research and telling us about this
um really important uh chapter in
history i want to thank everyone in the
audience for coming i want to urge you
all to please um
sign up to be on the ypsa mailing list
um this is our last talk for this year
but we'll have many important um
lectures next year too and uh please
join me in thanking david deyong for
that um great presentation today thank
you
it was my pleasure it's really nice to
be here and good luck with uh yeah thank
you very much yeah okay bye everybody